the first minister of scotland nicola
sturgeon thank you very much for being
with us want to start off by talking to
you about the local elections a recent
surveillation poll suggesting the snp
could be on track for its best ever
performance what would success look like
for you
and also do you think that labour could
actually overtake the conservatives to
become the main opposition in scotland
well responding to the latter part of
your question first i i don't know what
i do know is that we have a situation in
scottish politics where labour and the
conservatives by their own admission are
still scrapping it out for second place
and i'm quite happy to leave them to do
that and concentrate on persuading
people across scotland again that they
should vote snp for good strong reasons
what would be a good result i want to
win the election i fight every election
hoping to win it but i take absolutely
nothing for granted i think voting snp
in this election firstly elects strong
snp councillors
elects snp councils that can work with
my government in hollywood to do
everything we can to help people
struggling with the cost of living right
now but the election is also an
opportunity to send a very clear and a
very loud and emphatic message to boris
johnson to tell boris johnson that
people are
disgusted at his antics and really
frustrated at his inaction and that of
the chancellor on the cost of living so
that's the opportunity people across
scotland indeed people in many parts of
the uk have on thursday
of course they might be voting on issues
a bit closer to home as well issues like
the recent controversy over two ferry
contracts in scotland 150 million pounds
over budget
five years late i mean often i think uh
to you know viewers across the country
you're seeing as someone who's very on
top of the details someone who's
competent but to be honest i really
don't understand how buying two ferries
can go so badly wrong this is the
epitome of incompetence isn't it
well firstly to agree with you on the
point that people will vote on a whole
host of issues and people yes will vote
um and record a verdict on the
performance of me as first minister and
my government that's what elections are
about it's in the nature of energy
rightly said opinion polls suggest that
people will vote smp more than they will
vote for other parties but i don't take
that for granted on the ferries an issue
in terms of the delay to those two
ferries and the cost overrun something i
have expressed regret about we're
focused on making sure we deliver those
ferries the history of that issue of
course is that two ferries were procured
the shipyard in which they were being
constructed was in private ownership the
ferries it started to run over time and
over budget that private company the
shipyard then went into administration
and my government took it into public
ownership in order that we could
safeguard the future of commercial
shipbuilding on the river clyde and we
have secured that there are 400 people
working in the that shipyard now earning
a wage supporting their families that
wouldn't be in those jobs but for the
decisions my government had taken and
we're focused now with new management at
that shipyard which is now of course in
public ownership to get those ferries
completed but i absolutely one of the
things i think it's important to do when
you're a leader is to concede when
things don't go right because in the
nature of government not everything goes
right all of the time and when things go
wrong you have to face up to that and
you have to focus on putting it right
and that's what we are doing on this
particular issue i think the other thing
that people are really concerned about
over what happened with the ferries is
the lack of paperwork so there isn't
paperwork showing why the scottish
government awarded the contract in the
first place to the ferguson shipyard
that's according to the report by
scotland which by the way was against
the advice of the public body overseeing
it the caledonian maritime assets
limited what happened to that relevant
paperwork was it not done or was it lost
okay
well
the judgment of the auditor general who
of course heads up audit scotland and
was responsible for that report is that
this is a a single piece of
documentation amidst the 200 documents
the 1500 pages of documents that are
published that was not created that's
the judgment of the auditor general to
be very clear
though
can you
well i was going to explain i was going
to explain what it was if you if you let
me finish on the 8th of october 2015 a
submission it went to a minister setting
out the concerns of simal the
organization you
referred to a moment ago and setting out
the mitigations that had been taken to
address those concerns the next day a
letter went from transport scotland to
semale saying that ministers had taken
account of those risks and had decided
to proceed the piece of documentation
that apparently has not been created is
an email or a note in the middle of that
that would simply had it been created
have said something like the minister is
content on the basis of the
the reason set out on the 8th of october
so that's what is not there but anybody
who reads that and anybody can read it
if they're interested because it's all
published on the scottish government
website we'll be able to look at that in
its entirety and i think see at the
basis on which ministers took that
decision now that the the fact that that
piece of documentation is missing is
regrettable of course it is and we will
learn lessons but you know that is not
the reason the ferries are over
time and over budget these are complex
issues but they are deeply regrettable
issues not least for
the island communities in scotland that
are waiting for those ferrys so as i say
you know it's important in positions of
leadership in government to recognize
that many things go right every day but
some things don't go right to
acknowledge that to learn lessons and to
put them right and i think the fact you
know 15 years into government we mark 15
years in government this week the fact
that so many people in scotland still
support the snp suggest that they
perhaps appreciate that candid approach
to government and still think we're
doing lots of things right that they
support and want to vote for
okay and are you still committed to a
referendum on scottish independence in
the second half of the parliament which
would mean next year
at the first half of the parliament to
be
about it which would you're right at
that point i mean the the end of next
year well these things if i had just
agreed with you there are no doubt that
we've had lots of journalists trying to
suggest that i had changed my position
but the short answer question is yes
uh
russia i just want to um pick that
slightly russia a country of course with
nuclear weapons has invaded ukraine
and the world has obviously seen the
devastation that that has caused
is it still the snp policy that an
independent scotland should have no
nuclear weapons
i would want to see and this is
certainly the position of the snp and
independent scotland be a non-nuclear
member of nato um remember the vast
majority of countries in the world don't
have nuclear weapons and i think we're
seeing right now being reminded right
now of the dangers posed by nuclear
weapons but i would want an independent
scotland uh obvious that scotland is a
small country we have a strategically
important geographic position in the
north atlantic to be a constructive
and
participating member of nato and i think
one of the big questions for my party
indeed for those who support an
independent scotland is to think in this
new world order that we're living in
post the russian invasion of ukraine
where many of the things we've taken for
granted in the post-cold war era have
been turned in their head we need to
consider what would an independent
scotland bring to that nato alliance and
the question of nato membership has not
always been one that uh unifies
everybody in the snp but i think in the
world we're living and it's very
important to recognize that would be
vital for the security of an independent
scotland and we would have a duty to
play our part in that broader security
arrangement
just specifically on the nuclear weapons
you say there that you don't see you
know future of scotland having nuclear
weapons of course the uk's nuclear
submarine base is at faz lane which is
30 miles from glasgow so would a vote
for scottish independence be a vote to
immediately effectively strip the uk
of its nuclear capability
well we've and i've said this many times
before and the snp has made this clear
we are a non-nuclear party and obviously
there is a big assumption until i knew
question here that the snp would be in
government in an independent scotland i
hope that would be the case but i'm
speaking here for the policy of my party
but nuclear weapons are dangerous and we
would always be responsible in terms of
the negotiations around the timing and
the practical arrangements for the
removal of nuclear weapons from scotland
we would not be in any way irresponsible
about that but we're a non-nuclear party
and we would want an independent
scotland and i think this is the point
that is sometimes in the discussions in
scotland forgotten the vast vast
majority of countries across the world
are non-nuclear the vast majority of
nato members are non-nuclear countries
so that is the norm but of course when
we're talking about dealing with nuclear
weapons the
we have to be utterly responsible in
everything we do but the snp is firmly a
believer in being non-nuclear but we
would want to be a very constructive
member of the nato security alliance
it's interesting listening to talk
because you know you're talking about
wanting to be a constructive member of
nato if of course scotland had become
independent as you say that's not
something that the s p has always agreed
on you say you want to get rid of
nuclear weapons but you want to do it in
a responsible way
speaking to you personally has what's
happened in ukraine
change your thinking at all on some of
these big defense issues
yeah i mean i i think anybody who would
say to you
that what has happened in ukraine in
recent weeks hasn't if not changed
fundamentally the thinking made them
question all sorts of things it would
not be somebody you would want in a
leadership position so yes and i think
very carefully about these things i
think at trying to get to a world that
doesn't have nuclear weapons actually
seems to me to be more important now not
less important but one of the things
that um i have become more certain of is
that an independent scotland for the
security of scotland but also for the
security
of our part of the world would need to
be a fully constructive member of the
nato alliance the other thing that i
think we should all be reminded of is
how precious democracy is and how
important it is for all of us to be
prepared to stand up and defend
democracy i think putin has been allowed
you know through what he did in crimea
for example to get away with too much
for too long and i think we've all been
reminded the democracy is not something
that can just be taken for granted that
we've got to protect and defend it and
those of us who live in democracies in
countries like scotland where there is a
vigorous and passionate debate about
whether or not scotland should become an
independent country we should actually
thank our lucky stars that we live in a
country where we can debate these things
democratically and decide these things
democratically whatever side we happen
to be on yes or no to scottish
independence that is something to be
celebrated so we all have to we are
seeing all sorts of things that we've
taken for granted since the end of the
cold war now been turned on their heads
and all of us of a duty at the european
union countries within the european
union are rethinking long-held positions
so none of us are immune from that but
we've got to do that in a way that
recognizes core principles
but also recognizes the importance of
countries independent countries working
collaboratively together for the sake of
our collective security
okay i want to talk to you a little bit
about the stories and the allegations
that have been
emerging in westminster more than 50
mps apparently uh referred to the
watchdog for allegations of sexual
misconduct we of course saw the case of
neil parish who's now resigned for
watching pornography in the house of
commons
now of course he has resigned but there
are allegations that have been reported
about some smp
mps as well aren't they
can you confirm whether or not the rgcs
parliament's watchdog has upheld a
complaint of sexual harassment about
patrick grady
i don't know i've seen what has been
reported as i understand that the
process is underway i have not seen any
findings and i'm not trying to dodge
this it's important that the process is
allowed to proceed uh when i do know uh
whether the the finally things have been
upheld i'm happy to come on and talk to
you about that and i'm happy to be open
about what i think should happen in
those circumstances but i don't know
what if anything has been upheld and it
would therefore be wrong and actually
not possible for me to go into detail
about that but what i will say is i i
think parties cannot simply throw stones
when it's people in other parties who
are being found guilty of these things
we all have to apply these standards to
ourselves and i will not shy away from
that when i do know what the outcome of
these processes are
okay um of course uh you're right to say
that they are allegations we don't know
you know the full facts at this stage
very important to say that and at the
same time though
if you are someone who you know is
always proud of themselves or on
rooting out sexism or criticizing other
parties if you feel that they're not
doing the same
should someone not be suspended or have
the whip suspended while investigations
are ongoing
look these investigations are ongoing i
have it's not that long ago probably
around about this time last year i was
on your program and being rightly i
hauled over the calls by you
in a journalistic sense of course uh
over the alex hammond allegations about
what i knew when uh and you know these
things are are difficult but i you know
ended up in a position where i was
subject to investigation there because i
wasn't prepared to see allegations
simply swept under the carpet so i agree
with you it's really important uh when
things conclude in a particular way for
parties to take responsibility for that
and act appropriately in this case
though the process is ongoing i don't
know
what if anything has been upheld and i'm
going to wait for that process to
conclude and then i'm happy to come back
on your program and talk about it in
detail at that point okay a bit more uh
widely uh should try and sort of get the
bigger picture now on misogyny and
sexism directed towards women in public
life we of course
remember the coverage of angerina's
so-called basic instinct moment when she
was apparently just crossing and
crossing her legs
you're no stranger to run-ins about
coverage of yourself by a certain
newspapers i remember the infamous front
page of you and theresa may
in the daily mail when you were talking
about brexit never mind brexit headline
who won legs it
um how big a problem is sexism uh
towards female politicians
it's a massive problem and
it's not getting better yet in fact in
some ways i think it's getting worse um
i think social media has made it worse
and is also made easier for those who
want to be sexist and misogynist towards
women in the public eye to have access
to them direct access to them and you
know i i sometimes think speaking
personally and this is possibly wrong
i've been in politics so long i've been
subjected to that kind of stuff for so
long that i'm maybe personally a bit
nerd to it and and i shouldn't be
but i am very conscious of the impact
that has on younger women you know we're
fighting a council election campaign and
i'm speaking for the snp here but i'm
pretty sure other parties would say the
same this election more than any
election i've been involved in certainly
any election have led to the snp and
it's been really difficult to get women
to come forward and stand for election
because there is a sense that politics
and public life is not a safe space for
women anymore and we need to do
something about that because we're going
to rule the day if we continue down this
path and women just don't see
the ability to come forward and be
active in politics so it's a real
problem in politics and in public life
but it's a societal problem sexism
misogyny and it's a spectrum from
inappropriate comments at one end of
that spectrum through to
serious sexual assault and murder at the
other end of that spectrum it's time to
draw a line in the sand you know not all
men are misogynist and we still feel the
need to say that but it's true but all
women
experience misogyny and it's a problem
of male behavior we've just had baroness
helena kennedy do a report for us in
scotland and she has proposed new
criminal laws
against misogyny which we are now taking
forward in the scottish parliament but
fundamentally this is about men
accepting that they are the problem and
changing and if we don't start to change
this quickly then the consequences and
the implications are going to be really
severe not just for politics
but for women in public life more
generally okay thank you very much for
being on the program today nicolas
sturgeon there thank you